what the was that hi everyone my name is
Tamra chambers and this is Tara just saw
and I just went and saw serenity sorry
if my framing is weird I never do these
myself but I'm home alone so I'm
terrible at everything this uh I'm not
really sure how to dive into this so
forgive me if I seem a little disheveled
I don't know if it's because I saw Dark
City for this week's Tamara just saw but
I guessed the ending of this I actually
guessed the ending of a twist movie it's
never happened to me before and I was
very excited I just wish that it was a
movie that I liked this movie is about
Matthew McConaughey's character John who
is a troubled fisherman who drinks a lot
and has sex a lot and doesn't make very
much money he's looking for this giant
tuna and then his ex-wife Anne Hathaway
comes in and tells him that she needs
him to kill her now husband because he's
hurting her and both of their sons said
when there's one son you get all that in
the trailer honestly I know actually I
think the trailers really good it made
me go hmm oh I was very interested in
the trailer it was super intriguing and
then they didn't carry that into the
full movie I don't really think you know
and I'm seeming pretty harsh on this
film I don't know what to think of it I
do think they were going for something
really ambitious and I do think that
they think that they accomplished that I
loved the acting I think acting was
great I think that the writing was not
great I'm not gonna do full spoilers in
this or I won't say that what the twist
is but I don't know just if you don't
want anything ruins maybe don't watch
this I'm so uncomfortable I don't know
why this movie made me so
first of all the twist was revealed in
the middle of the movie I said that I
guess the twist I guessed the parameters
of the twist it's a pretty weirdly
specific twist that makes zero sense you
get to the end of the movie and you're
like okay thank you for you know giving
us all of your eggs in your basket in
the middle of the film and then at the
end is not really explaining anything
outside of it it's didn't wrap up in a
way that's like oh wow like you get the
twist and it's not like Oh
[Music]
mind blown crazy and then end you get
the twist and you're like huh okay so we
still have 4045 minutes left so where
are we gonna go now oh you don't know
either okay Matthew McConaughey is such
a damn weirdo he is so so weird I think
he acted his heart out and this I think
he did a really good job I can imagine
him reading this script and being like
oh oh alright alright alright do you get
it that's what he says I think he
probably read the script it was like
this is gonna be a masterpiece and then
I imagine that other people were like oh
cool Matthew McConaughey is on board
let's do this the cast is killer
there's a full of amazing actors and I
think they did a really good job I just
think that the right because the
direction seemed good and the
cinematography was gorgeous the editing
for what it was had a good pace with the
writing I think was the the big issue
here it just made no goddamn sense and
it really gave away too much too soon
the writing of the characters it it
replaced like good characters with just
like a lot of character backstory like
you knew a lot about these characters
but you still didn't really get a sense
of who they were because you're not
writing them whelmed in the now and in
the moment that they're here you're
writing them well for like their past
and they instead of being in the moment
and like talking to the other characters
in like a good and substantial way
they're just like explaining their past
and it's like we don't we don't care
about the past
of the woman that Matthew McConaughey
sleeps with on this island they we just
don't her cat has this killer back story
but your plot it's just the character
work is so weird and so surface level
and I guess it kind of ties into the
twist at the end or the twist in the
middle but it still isn't good the way
that they're written Matthew
McConaughey's dialogue and at the end a
half of the film is just him standing in
a boat throwing his arms back and
yelling to the sea ah you know a lot of
those you see a lot of Matthew
McConaughey butt and penis outline these
showers in the ocean which is pretty
disgusting I'll be honest
three minutes in I've already said WTF
like seven times I like that I was
saying WTF seven times I I really like
that they kept you kind of like what is
happening like until the twist was
revealed in the middle I was like I
really just don't fully understand
what's what's going on here you know
there's the Anne Hathaway story and then
there's him trying to find this big tuna
story and then there's this weird guy
who works for a fishing company who's
like trying to get his attention and he
is that's his own story and it just
doesn't feel cohesive at all
then all of a sudden talk about other
storylines all of a sudden there's just
some magic happening between him and his
son and it's really not explained and
it's not done in a way that I guess when
you find out what it is it makes sense
but it just it it annoyed me that there
were something else added to this verses
like made me question it made me think
oh my gosh this is gonna be so cool
it was just like why is there this other
aspects that you're adding to this movie
that's already filled with so much what
is why what huh Wow wit why
I liked it though what I don't know I
can't really tell you what I didn't like
about it because it seriously left a bad
taste in my mouth but thinking back on
it now there were some really cool parts
again acting was really cool it's just
it's got to be the writing because like
there's a point where were Matthew
McConaughey is kind of figuring out
what's going on with him and this story
and it's really cool he's super
compelling in that and like putting
pieces together and the people in this a
little Ireland are really cool and
creepy and I don't know it just missed
the mark so epically and I think he
could have been really really really
cool but I imagine that this is gonna go
like kind of under the radar then just
disappear it's got a very like shutter
island'
dark city again vibe but I didn't like
this as much as I liked those other two
but yeah I'm you know it was just it was
it was just hmm it's a real January
movie I'll say thank you so much for
watching let me know what you think of
serenity did I miss the mark here was it
secretly brilliant and it just confused
me cuz that happens before okay with
things like mother when mother came out
and everyone was like oh my god it's so
pretentiously artsy and like and I know
it's not the same kind of thing that was
artsy and this is like a weird twist
kind of deal but I don't know like it
intrigued me I think I'm easily
intrigued while watching movies and this
one it didn't read me for sure but I
think it just missed the mark it yep
eclis missed the mark and I feel bad for
the actors involved because they were
just giving it they were giving it their
all and so yeah yeah yeah let me know
what you think I am not sure what I
think obviously wow it's hammer a really
good reaction
my word thank you for watching I will
see well next week with another January
video no it will be February is that
even better I don't know okay bye
[Music]
you